NIGHTMARE?E
THAT'S THESTORTHE
BAONN 14BROADUS AND HIS MARIA U
HORB
NERSEY.
AFREHE SCANDOR
LETTERS FROMANONYMOUS
DO KIN THEHAVE ENTHR HER ANHEM.
WALL 657 BOULEVA
THREATENYOU HERED T.WRITER SHOW
AND DRAW THE ME.
TO THE POLIC A
INVESTIGATOR.
LEARD  THEM. WATCHER" BASED ON O
PUBLISD UEST,
RECENTLYITED THE CASTA
WATCHER, WNOW ABE
SE F A"NEW RK"
OVER WHATIERIOD?>> THE FAMIL BA
SIX WE THE
US
AND BEYONDHAE T  -THOTHER TTY B
CACONTROVERSY.
>> AND, REEVES, OW FROM GR THE
FORM HAD RECEIVED ONE
SIMIR .
PART OF THAT SELLEISCLOSE
IT?
>> NO, THEREASN'T.
A AND THALE HERE IT'S SORTF IN A
KINOFN UNUSUAL
E HOUSE THE LE
WASN'THREATENINERHAT
THE BRDURECEIVED.
TH
ETIT WAS EIGHT YEARS
INT HAPPENED
PLACE AND RIN
DOORBELLS.
NO VIDEO, NOE THE
ANO  ON
>> THERE WASN'T ANVIDEO. THE
THE IL SO IST
AND D IT OFF.
EVENTUALLY INVESTIRS
ACTUALLY PUT CAMERT ICE TOO SE
ECANYO COMINTO DRONG OFF BUTT .
EVIDCEISA SAMPLE FROM ONOF
ENVELOPES.
HUTHE ONLY TNGHAT WE
TH WAS ASO IAS
PERSON WHO LIC WPPY A WOMAN.
>> IS ITTIVE
N?
THIS?TFIELD COPS STILLN
REA
THERE WAS AHIT ESCALATED TO
UNTY PROSECUTOR'S
IT'S NOWEEYONCE CASEAMT,OR FOUR
OUR STOR OUT ANDRE-EIZON
AGAIN.
I'VEEET SHORT OF E  A ROMINAD,
HAVEN' CASE, BUT
THEY ALS ACTIV
IN AINM YOUR
THE REA
TAKEN BY NFLN TAKEN IT, I
GELLY NEVER MOVED INTOHE
THEY WERE ENGAGED IN RENOVATIONS
AND EY CRASC THEIR
O TH I
LIEVE WHEN THEY
E
RUBUGO
UH-O I HOPE GOING TOET LETTER H
US.
WERE THERE LETTERS SEN
THOAS DID ANY
LETTGOR DID BUY
USOR DT END?T WAS OBVIOUSL
BUT EY BOTTTERHOTH
OWNERS ALSO HAVEN'T GOTTEN ANY
LETTERS.ER WAS DOING THIS, IEEHO
EA LL THEANUG
REALIZINW AWFUL THIS WAS
WHATEVER REASON IT IS -- ODEAD
POSSIBILITY.AT'S ALSO AI
>> K AREVERSIO